[موسيقى]
انتخابات التجديد النصفي تتزامل مع الحرب
في اوكرانيا التي قوضت اقتصاد العالم 30
انتخابات النصفيه جارت في القرن الماضي في
الولايات المتحده تزامن بعضها مع حروب او
نزاعات عسكريه شاركت فيها امريكا بشكل
مباشر او غير مباشر وانعكست على نتائجها
في الاثني عشر جوله من جولات التجديد
النصفي التي خسرها حزب الرئيس الامريكي ان
عقدت ثمان جولات منها تزامنا او عقب حروب
تاثر بها الشان الامريكي
الحربان العالميتان القطا بظلالهما
القادمه على الاقتصاد الامريكي كانت
المحصله خساره الحزب الديمقراطي اغلبيه
مجلس الشيوخ النواب في استحقاقي تجديد
النصفي عام
1918 و 294
اما الحزب الجمهوري فاخسر اغلبيه الغرفتين
اثناء سيطرته على الرئاسه الامريكيه عام
1986 و 2990 وهي الانتخابات التي جرت
بالتزامن مع الحرب السوفيتي على
الافغانستان والحرب العراقيه الايرانيه
صحيح انها تيل الحربين لم تتدخل فيهما
واشنطن بشكل مباشر الا ان دعمها لاحد
طرفيها لم يتوقف ابان فتره حكم بوشنكم
[موسيقى]
اما العام 2002 فكان الوضع استثنائيا خلال
المده الاولى لبوش الابن وفي اعقاب هجمات
ال 11 من سبتمبر تجمع الامريكيون خلفه حزب
الرئيس وفاز الجمهوريون باغلبيه بسيطه
بلغت ثمانيه مقاعد في مجلس النواب لكن
لاحقا على جورج بوش الابن نفس معاناه ابيه
ففي اول انتخابات عقبه حربي العراق
وافغانستان خاسره حزبه الجمهوري اغلبيه
الكونجرس بغرفتي في انتخابات عام 2006